I can't wait for the Epstein trial when
they start to shame the victims you know
that's coming yeah you know some some
defense attorneys gonna be like okay um
I guess it's time to hear from these
hoes maybe some of these hoes can get up
on they gonna they gonna you gonna tell
us some story BB one of the girls okay
hello in your name your name state your
name for the record
Jessica hi Jessica are you aware of the
defendant you know the defendant yeah
yes you do huh yeah you know Jeff yeah I
do
he point him out right there yeah honey
right there he gave you right on his
plane he did oh he did huh yes did you
pay for that ride I did not she was a
free ride on its plane I guess you took
a free ride on the plane Jessica huh
yeah do you know much fuel costs
I got a 737 I I do not you have no idea
no do you just waltz right on the put
did he force you to get on the plane I
um I don't think snow so you just got on
the plane and you got and you took a
trip he said we were just taking a trip
they have vacation and you went to a
private island yes yeah so let me get
this straight
you took a free trip to a private island
okay on my clients dawn and the only
thing you had to do was suck Alan
Dershowitz his old [ __ ] have you ever
sat middle seat on a Spirit Airlines
flight Jess I have you know how many
[ __ ] I put my mouth to never do that I
did you have your own seat on the plane
Jessica oh you did huh yeah you're out
see you had your own room on the plane
didn't you had a bed
I yeah oh you had a bed I was tied up
but yeah okay because of turbulence
because of turbulence I didn't think of
and all you had to do was take a few
loads from the leader of the free world
Rhodes Scholar
do you know good the economy was when
President Clinton was in Jessica do you
any idea I was very young I don't write
so the mastermind of one of the greatest
boom times ever wanted to empty a few
loads on your tummy in a private chat
and suddenly the world owes you
something I hate hey [ __ ] are you
serious right now
look at this jury of poor people are you
see they've never been to an island they
went to sandals once like a Tiffany
Haddish is the lawyer you know she will
be in the movie [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah but you
know that's gonna go down yeah yeah
it'll be like we're you know reverse
Kavanaugh
these are all so fun but none of them
can ever go on social media you gotta
listen to the podcast folks you got to
listen because we cannot take the chance
of putting these things up because
they're coming for us we were on a list
we've been shadow band somebody who
follows me goes I look you up your sixth
and I follow you you come up like six
shadow band